there are some more places where the
push for opportunity and diversity has
fallen short that includes the cockpits
of the nation's commercial airliners the
latest figures show only about 7% of
pilots and flight engineers or people of
color but one mentorship is trying to
change that by inspiring young people to
reach for the skies defeat salad on
there for as long as eighteen-year-old
Davion Lee can remember he's dreamed of
soaring high I was like about three
years old I was walking with my parents
I looked up I saw airplane it said mom I
want to fly that one day has just been a
passion I've ruined me ever since you
are hooked it's three years old yes so
you get turn right now pilot Jerome
Stanislaus is taking him under his wing
throwing up Stanislaus also found an
interest in flying but he didn't have
the same guidance I kind of put myself
in a box and you know told myself that I
would never probably be a pilot's
because I actually never saw a pilot
that you know that looked like myself
just over two and a half percent of
aircraft pilots and flight engineers are
African American according to the Bureau
of Labor Statistics so last year
Stanislaus started giving free flights
often to kids of color Aviation is just
it's a very expensive hobby and it's
also equally as expensive as a career to
get into is definitely a barrier for so
many people he's part of fly for the
culture a nonprofit that promotes
inclusion in aviation when you take a
kid up for the first time you see their
reaction oh it's it's priceless
six-year-old boogie burns three-year-old
brother Tyler landed with mixed
reactions
you might want to be a pilot when you
grow up yeah why you fell asleep in the
back Stanislas hopes these kids can see
themselves in him and spark an interest
they didn't know they had I'm spending
this money to you know do this charity I
guess when I could really be using it to
you know further my own career why do
you do it
because I love it
I'm sorry
you know and I really want to be able to
make a difference and this is how I do
it you know it's like my purpose a
purpose that is making a difference it's
inspirational to know that there's
somebody who looks like me who was doing
what I want to do and he's helping me
out proving that it's always better to
have someone there along for the ride
you know he on average spends what
fifteen hundred to two thousand dollars
to take people up and he says he just
charges that credit card and you think
about african-americans in particular in
aviation
you know Bessie Coleman back in the
1920s
she made a name for herself before
Amelia Earhart did an African American
woman
the Tuskegee Airmen same thing through
military a great tradition but something
has happened over the last 20 to 30
years you aren't seeing those numbers
grow and so this is one of the one of
the ways that way to respond to that
there's no better reward than to hear
bogey say this is the best day of month
and you're never too young to be hooked